hey there help you what state is this
sorry
you don't understand the question I know
I didn't most people know where they are
quiet most people you're in the glorious
State Arkansas sweetheart
that you know they was lying well this
ain't Arkansas so everyone is lying
your idea is incredible
they can't argue with that we pay for
everything so this country belongs to us
it's just business
panting human beings for sport there are
not human beings every year a bunch of
the leaks kidnap normal folk like us
where'd they get you from Wyoming asipi
land up and hunt us for sport hurry
hurry
so it's true we're being hunted what I'm
gonna wait was having put him in the
back with the rest
[Music]
train
I don't care
[Music]
now they can't see us you just told them
we're here what was that
I think that was a rifle
who are these people Hara they get away
with this
you have no idea what you're up against
they're playing you okay to the pieces
we'll say that of all the people you
kidnap of all the people you kill you
pick the wrong game lady you're crazy
you